il est difficile de transformer une
ville moyenne industrielle en cité
touristique et besançon en fait
l'expérience
on y vante bien sûr son charme une
certaine douceur fait d'ombré de
vieilles pierres mais cela suffit qu'il
a détourné les touristes d'un itinéraire
plus propice autant qu beauté du site
en fait la capitale franc comtoise
souffre sur le plan touristique d'un
atout commercial industriel pesant son
est avant tout un carrefour
nous on reste toujours un grand centre
de poids sol compte tenu de sa situation
sur les grands axes touristiques nord
sud emprunté par les allemands et les
plus touristiques ouest est empruntée
par les anglais et les ressortissants du
benelux donc désormais on reste toujours
une grande île de passage en ce qui
concerne le séjour on peut considérer
d'après les quelques indications que
j'ai pu recueillir auprès des
professionnels de l'hôtellerie qu'il y
aurait une certaine baisse de
fréquentation dans les établissements
visons les touristes et pour quelques
fois de difficultés à s'y retrouver
même les bisontins sur tout ce qui
rentre de vacances enfin c'est une
situation provisoire
ce plan de circulation il m'appartient
pas de juger
je pense qu était nécessaire de faire
quelque chose à besançon on pourra juger
des effets du plan de circulation
lorsqu'il sera complètement terminée car
le touriste lui est avide de souvenirs
de recueillement une cherche loin des
plages et du soleil la douceur le calme
ils jouent les historiens ou les
photographes
et quand on lui offre en plein mois
d'août une cité admirer ventre et le
labyrinthe des rues à contresens du
bruit permanent et de la poussière
que pense-t-il
ils pensent peut-être que le progrès
passent par là mais que le progrès n'est
pas fait pour les vacances alors il va
plus loin
loin de nous l'idée de juger mais il est
un fait qu un tel bouleversement à peine
compris des bisontins risque encore
moins de ravir les touristes le syndicat
d'initiative n'est pas le premier à se
plaindre
le plan de circulation d'accord mais
pourquoi pendant l'été tout le bilan de
la saison touristique à besançon posera
se fait en évidence la saison est faussé
les antennes du syndicat d'initiative à
valentin appuyer les vignes haber ne
change rien moins de touristes cette
année sauf miracle à la fin du mois
mais on peut bien sûr à titre
d'information et à pied cette fois-ci
visité les travaux de la ville
quant à l'hôtellerie le bilan provisoire
provisoire bien entendu est
catastrophique
si l'on en croit ses responsables
en ce qui me concerne personnellement
les affaires au mois de juillet se
traduit sa façon suivante
environ 250 chambres de louer en moins
que le même mois l'an dernier et 9 cents
couverts c'est à dire globalement une
baisse d'environ 20% insupportable qui
est dû à quoi de prévu
sachant que nos collègues des localités
environnantes ont tout benne jusqu'à
présent tenu le coup un même dans
d'excellentes conditions et bien je ne
peux dire qu'une chose c'est
qu'apparemment le plan de circulation
tous les travaux qu'ils entraînent etc
sont en cause dans cette affaire-là
nous avons fait d'énormes efforts nous
vous apportons maintenant tout frais
émoulu tout neuf
le mercure avec ses 60 chambres novotel
va suivre derrière avec ses 100 chambres
haut c'est le moment de dire on fait de
buzz en font une ville de congrès une
ville de tourisme une ville de
saint-claude y sommes et pourquoi pas
encore une ville thermale bientôt 12 100
chambres d'hôtel un ensemble capable
d'accueillir des manifestations
d'envergure reste alors une politique
globale du tourisme l'autoroute a36 dans
trois ans risque de faire oublier
besançon il faudra alors faire quitter
l'autoroute aux touristes mais à quel
prix